while casting key roles in high-profile
films it seems like Hollywood looks at
every star in the industry tossing a
half a dozen names into the rumor mill
before finally making up their minds
these are roles however that were
destined for one actor and one actor
only and it's easy to see why
Rubeus Hagrid because of the UK only
casting policy mandated by Harry Potter
author JK Rowling several American
actors who were keen to get in on the
Hogwarts action were turned away without
so much as an audition including the
legendary Robin Williams who had his eye
on the role of groundskeeper Rubeus
Hagrid the Rowling herself only ever
envisioned one man for the role veteran
actor Robbie Coltrane how are you Rubeus
Hagrid keeper of keys and grains at
Hogwarts it's tough to imagine anyone
else in the role of the gentle half
giant based on a Hells Angel biker
Rowling once knew fans will recall that
Hagrid's first appearance is aboard a
flying motorcycle which now makes a bit
more sense
Hellboy for most of his career Ron
Perlman was known as a talented actor
who almost always appeared under layers
of makeup and prosthetics his first film
role was as a Neanderthal in 1981 s
quest for fire and his breakout gig came
in 1987 starring opposite Linda Hamilton
in the TV series Beauty and the Beast so
it makes sense Guillermo del Toro
favoured him for the lead role in his
2004 adaptation of The Dark Horse comic
series Hellboy so intent with del Toro
on casting Perlman in the title role
that he turned down a bigger budget a
bevy of a-list actors and two studios in
his quest to get the film made in
particular Universal virtually forced
del Toro to talk with multiple major
stars about the role for years only for
the determined del Toro to repeat his
mantra to executives after every meeting
yeah I like the guy but I like Ron
Perlman more nada John Carpenter's they
live is a dystopian sci-fi b-movie
masterpiece with a protagonist never
referred to by name in the spell
but the credits call him nada nada is a
stone-faced homeless drifter who
discovers Fiat magic sunglasses that
aliens are living in her midst
controlling all of society and he deals
with this information in his own unique
way I have come here to chew bubblegum
and kick ass and I'm all audible it's a
roll carpenters fans would have expected
to see Kurt Russell it and practically
nobody else the carpenters longtime Muse
wasn't even considered nobody was except
the professional wrestler with a rather
limited acting resume rowdy roddy piper
brought deft low-key charm and a rugged
everyman presence to the role carpenter
says piper was quote just absolutely
perfect so i never thought of anybody
else Nick Fury in 2002 Marvel comics
artists Mark Miller was asked to
redesign some classic characters for
Marvel's ultimate line one of these was
shield director Nick Fury the eyepatch
sporting superspy who had previously
been portrayed by David Hasselhoff and a
little remembered TV movie
Miller envisioned his version of Fury as
an update to the characters cool 60 spy
aesthetic and deciding the name had a
select location bent to it decided to
cast his fury in the image of the
coolest man alive samuel l.jackson
unbeknownst marvel's riders jackson was
a huge comics fan and fully aware of the
homage from the beginning the update was
well received by fans and Marvel Studios
overlord Kevin Feige made an on-the-fly
decision to cast Jackson as fury an Iron
Man's famous post-credit stinger a scene
that wasn't even in the original script
the rest is history as fury became the
glue that holds the Marvel Cinematic
Universe together and the latest in a
long series of iconic roles for the
beloved actor Drax the destroyer former
wrestler Dave Bautista is pitch perfect
as the not understanding what an idiom
is juggernaut Drax the destroyer in
Marvel's guardians of the galaxy fear
he's got a completely literal metaphors
are going to go over it nothing goes
over my head my reflexes are too fast
there were persistent rumors that the
role was first offered to Jason Momoa
who then flipped franchises to portray
Aquaman and DC's extended universe while
Malala confirms that he did addition for
the role of Drax he says he removed
himself from consideration before an
offer was made and the talks never got
as far as fans speculated visiting on
the set of the first film in 2013 Yahoo
movies put the final nail in the rumors
coffin confirming with cast and crew
that Bautista while not hand-picked in
the start was indeed the one and only
actor ever offered the role the singular
David Bowie generally considered to be
the better of 2006 --is two magicians at
the turn of the century films
Christopher Nolan's the prestige is a
solid thriller about the links to which
two old-timey magicians would go in
order to screw with each other
Hugh Jackman and Christian Bale headed
up an excellent cast which included an
absolutely inspired choice to play
insane genius Nikola Tesla David Bowie
the thin white duke himself delayed
bowie had a famously otherworldly
presence and Nolan never considered
anybody else to portray the enigmatic
inventor almost twenty years prior Bowie
was also Martin Scorsese's first and
only choice for the icy Pontius pilot in
1988 The Last Temptation of Christ his
performance was singled out among
critics as being more appropriate to the
material than that of his co-stars
proving Scorsese understood that casting
is much the same as life when you gotta
have David Bowie you gotta have David
Bowie go home forget this thing I can
recognize an obsession
no good will come thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel let's check out all
this cool stuff we know you love to
[Music]